the world health organization's chief is
optimistic covet 19 may be defeated this
year and some scientists say the milder
omicron variant could be the beginning
of the end of the pandemic but as such
confidence justified this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy nabogada it's now the third year
of the pandemic kova 19 has infected
nearly 300 million people and killed
five and a half million
numbers of infections are breaking
records almost every day across north
america europe and asia the omicron
variant is behind much of that surge
scientists in britain believe a person
sick with the strain can infect three to
five others far more than with the delta
variant
the world health organization warns the
two variants could combine and cause
what it calls a tsunami of infections
around the world
despite this the director general
believes the pandemic can end this year
if countries work together
but i still remain optimistic
that this can be the year we can not
only end the acute stage of the pandemic
but we also chart a path to stronger
health security
building on the successes and failures
we must not only share vaccines faster
and more equitably with kovacs and avat
we must support countries in
manufacturing
and rolling them out to everyone
and access to new treatments
must also follow well since its
discovery in southern africa in november
many studies have found the omicron
variant causes milder disease than
others admissions to hospitals in the
u.s uk and denmark are lower than during
previous waves and south africa says it
may have passed its peak some scientists
believe omicron will displace delta and
become endemic like the seasonal flu but
others are more cautious as kamal
santamaria explains
you may have heard dr chadros the head
of the world health organization talking
about the twin threats of delta and
omicron but whether it's a twin threat
to you and your particular part of the
world well that depends i'm going to
show you some maps first of all from our
world in data the red map is showing
omicron infections or at least where
omicron is more prevalent pretty easy to
see and no surprise that down in south
africa that's where we first saw omicron
also australia uh india and russia but i
would draw your attention to europe have
a look the uk yes we know there is a
prevalence of omicron in the uk but the
rest of europe is not as badly affected
it is dealing with
delta change to the blue map actually
i'll change back and forth have a look
at the change across europe between the
omicron and the delta maps you can see
there is a lot more delta to deal with
in europe as there is in south america
and parts of southeast asia now just to
give this a slightly different take i've
chosen nine different countries here and
we're looking at their share of
different infections the red is omicron
the blue a delta infection so starting
at the top south africa has got a rate
of 96
omicron now maybe that's a good thing
having more cases of the milder variant
further down the list
let's look at the united states for
example here which has sort of got a 60
40 split between the two but i think
what's interesting and i'm going to try
to draw a box around all of them here
are these european countries italy
france and germany with rates of 80 to
90
of delta
the more concerning variant if i can put
it that way of kova 19 and maybe that's
why their restrictions are a little bit
tighter in those sorts of countries the
question now is is omicron perhaps
the lesser of two evils
let's bring in our guests joining us
from dalha is hadiya sin who's the head
of research at qatar university's
biomedical research center
over in london is oxana pizzic who's the
lead at university college london's
global citizenship program on outbreaks
of infectious diseases and joining us
from bengaluru in india prasanna
saligram public health researcher and
member of the people's health movement
welcome to the program thank you for
speaking to us on inside story hadiya
sin um you heard the the director
general uh sounding pretty optimistic
that the pandemic can end this year if
he's saying countries work together
we've heard this call for global
solidarity
before so is his optimism justified or
is it misguided
no i assume this is the this is based on
scientific facts
based on two main facts if we can say
number one that the vaccine rate is
increasing in multiple countries and we
know that the vaccines are effective
especially if the people are taking the
third dose we know that the third dose
can provide some kind of protection
if not necessary from the infection but
at least from severe illnesses
even against omicron variant
number two there are there are more and
more reports showing that the omicron
variant although it's more transmissible
it cause milder disease especially in
the vaccinated uh individuals and
hopping
by the end of
2022 we have
we have like more people immune against
the the coronavirus
okay uh prasanna seligram uh the the who
chief was also warning that narrow
nationalism and vaccine hoarding
according to him by some countries have
undermined equity and created the ideal
conditions for the this new variant the
omicron variant to emerge do you agree
with that and um how do you think uh the
vaccine hoarding has allowed omicron to
emerge
yeah one
major aspect is that um less than 10
percent of africa is still vaccinated
and it is no accident
or
that the omicron variant emerged from
africa
so i think um
yeah we keep on repeating this statement
no one is safe until everyone is safe
but the global solidarity that is needed
is still missing uh even um after two
years of pandemic we are not seeing the
sort of global cooperation that is
needed
for um
what you call
wide
dispersal of vaccines and administration
of vaccines throughout the world but can
you definitely say
just on the point that you were
mentioning a moment ago about the
omicron variant emerging from southern
africa can you definitely say that the
omicron variant of the strain is linked
to vaccine inequality
vaccine inequality is um
not definitely in public health of
course you can't be definitely talking
about
certain things but definitely yes there
is a
situation of vaccine inequality wherein
for example south africa has not even
completed 23 percent of its uh
population i mean it has not vaccinated
even 23 percent of its population so
naturally
it's a prime ground or i mean this is
south africa with a better health system
and if you look at the other southern
african countries you have much
weaker health systems and hence we can
imagine what could be the situation
there so that that's the
point that i was trying to make okay uh
oksana przek um on this point of
inequality public health officials
warned at the time of the vaccine
rollout which was
correct me if i'm wrong here but about a
year ago now
they said that equitable vaccines was
essential to preventing mutations as
well as dangerous variants that would
prolong the pandemic
and here we are now we hear the same
calls for vaccine equality and
equity
what's gone wrong
well we took an approach which promoted
business as usual so
currently we have two companies in the
world that can make mrna vaccines those
are the pfizer
as well as the moderna companies
with that they have some licensing
agreements for example with the um
in various countries to to mass produce
including in india
uh but we should be leveraging global
vaccine manufacturing power uh as much
as possible as well as helping countries
to establish uh in the long term their
own manufacturing sites uh where there
currently are none
so there are two things here the world
trade organization has been
negotiating with countries to try and
really achieve
a mechanism by which
these vaccines can be made
more rapidly and they can be shared
in a way that currently patent laws
restrict
that argument however has uh let's say
lost steam in in uh because countries
like the uk germany um switzerland all
oppose this in order to protect their
industries
and if we're looking at uh the argument
around vaccine
equity we know that
in
largely unvaccinated populations where
there is more opportunity for
transmission and replication to occur
that we're just increasing the um really
probability of of uh variants to occur i
think we're now
looking at uh inept the inevitability
that more variants will emerge but
hopefully we will have the tools to
suppress the severity and that is why
the w sho is also now negotiating a w
cho pandemic treaty so that in future
there is a legally binding instrument
that will prevent uh vaccine hoarding uh
to occur so it right from the beginning
countries will be obligated to share
doses however this is of course
contingent upon all countries agreeing
and consensus has been something that's
been very difficult to arrive at in this
pandemic right and also oksana the the
who chief said that the his organization
aimed for a global vaccination rate by
of 70
and that's by july to end the pandemic
so looking at the way things have been
going up until this point do you think
that target is likely to be met
i think it's an ambitious target uh i
think that
it will likely take longer than that if
the current level of cooperation stays
where it is and if we don't see a
radical change in mindset countries have
made donations but those dollars have
not translated into doses or jabs in
arms and while places in the uk are now
have their
up to 30 of their population boosted
other countries have yet to get up to
ten percent of their country even with
the first doses and that includes health
care workers where one in four
healthcare workers in africa are
currently unvaccinated and these are the
people who are at highest risk so we
really need to start to think about
things more creatively than we have been
to ensure that we can get a a
quicker resolution to the end of the
pandemic if this does not mean the end
of cobit 19 it means the end of the
acute phase and where we can manage it
without the same pressure that we're
experiencing here uh with
hospitalizations and in the uk there are
massive uh workforce shortages as a
result of omicron and with a
steep incline of not only cases but
we're starting to see those first
signals of a creaking nhs right okay um
have you seen how do as a virologist i
wonder if you can explain to us how do
um inequities actually prolong the
pandemic so as as was mentioned by the
other colleagues so if you if you have a
community that's not immune to the virus
the virus will have the opportunity to
replicate and as its replicate and
transmit from one person to another it
acquires
more and more mutations and this means
we are going to have more and more
variants
that circulate
in the in the population there is one
note i want to mention in here is that
regarding omicron variant
the number of mutations that the omicron
variant obtained
from my perspective it seems that it was
it emerged through unusual events so
it's not like uh
mainly through like a transmission from
one person to another person
uh because um if if it is like that way
we could have detected like earlier than
that
but for me like omicron variant because
of the number of the because of the high
number of imitation it could be one of
two reason how it's it emerged it's
either it's like transmitted to animals
and
came back to human or it has been
evolving through
immunocompromised patients like hiv so
in terms of omacron variants i don't
think
the
vaccine
the vaccine shortage in certain regions
have led to the emergence of omicron
variants
so what you're saying is if inequalities
in vaccine access continue then adi we
will continue to see mutant strains of
this coronavirus
yes because like if you are immune even
if you are infected with the virus the
virus will not replicate for a long
period of time so like it will replicate
for a longer period in non-immune people
and that will give her that give it the
chance to mutate and as transmit from
one person to another
the mutations will be acquired and
become stable in these variants and if
you are immune then the virus have less
chance to to
to replicate for a longer period of time
and less chance to mutate it's still
going to mutate but the mutation rate
will be much lower
okay understood uh prasanna i'm going to
ask you to respond to what hadi said
because i saw you nodding along and also
i'd like you to tell us because we hear
a great deal about the situation across
europe and we've spoken about uh africa
as well but what is the situation in
bengaluru where you are when it comes to
the omnicron variants
yes so uh first i'll answer the second
question sure um we are going through
uh
a phase wherein we are having rapid
increase in cases
in the last four days our um
kovitt count has gone up four times
so we were at 5000 till about five days
back and now we are at 27 000 cases so
there is a rapid increase in the number
of cases so that is uh the
ground situation we have vaccinated
almo ninety percent with one dose but uh
sixty uh sixty percent of eligible
population i'm talking about uh with
both the doses and we have uh fallen
short by about forty percent in uh
vaccinating so whatever i'm talking
about in the global scenario it has also
played out in india in the sense that
only two companies
and the indian government did not break
the monopolies so uh the two companies
were allowed to have their monopoly
and as a result of which
initially we had a shortfall and then
they transferred it to the private
sector the private sector could not use
the vaccines because it was
very costly and people could not access
so the issue of access equity
uh production
all of this are coming together and it
is playing out during the time of
pandemic so that is the
um first uh right the situation
yes
yeah okay the second is um responding to
heidi i think yeah the very fact that
there is an immunocompromised person who
doesn't have the immunity also speaks of
the legacy issues of the way access to
medicines have been or access to
vaccines have been so if an hiv patient
or anybody else who is immunocompromised
is having a variant or um or having the
virus within them then there is always a
chance that the virus mutates and that's
also the legacy issue if you look at the
inequitable access to medicines to hiv
and those sorts of
issues so the inequities are very stark
and the irony is that the countries
which are opposing the whole trips
waiver and for the release of the
patents and all those they are the ones
which are also going through fourth
fifth sixth waves the countries of
germany as
the person from uk talked about uk
they have been opposing this
trips waiver put in 15 months back by
india and south africa and they are
suffering also with the most number of
cases so i think europe and uk are
better off in breaking the monopolies
rather than holding on to the monopolies
if they if they want to be safe and
another classic case is israel right
which did not bother to immunize in
palestinians so there was vaccine
apartheid
other than vaccine iniquities you had
vaccine apartheid also being followed as
a result of which israel is forced to do
fourth booster rules okay and on that
note
let me bring you in exactly on that
point of boosters the the who also he
chief excuse me he did criticize some
nations for conducting uh sort of
blanket booster programs as he called
them while other states remain largely
unvaccinated so there is this uh view by
some of the wealthier nations that the
booster shop programs will perhaps find
their way um it'll help them find their
way out of the pandemic i mean can they
boost their way out of this pandemic and
how likely is it that it actually
achieves the opposite effect
well certainly multi-layered levels of
protection are going to be the most
effective relying on the vaccine alone
is partially why some countries have a
much higher
um
fourth fifth wave impact on their
healthcare system than others boosters
however uh we need to be talking about
them as a
and because at this point with omicron
unlike other variants there is
a huge amount of breakthrough infections
occurring so two doses clearly not
enough to really um
prevent the level of uh
impact on hospital hospitalizations
so again in the uk it's early days were
very early in the wave uh compared to
south africa where we saw um
that it's peaked but there are cautions
about comparing the uk too closely
because they had a previous built up
immunity from other variants and they
have a younger population so uh in that
instance it is necessary in this case
for us to ensure that boosters are
delivered alongside uh other doses
the uk
apologies but the uk i mean data out of
the uk very recently uh suggested that
protection against omicron starts to
wane after
10 weeks after that booster vaccination
so
does this suggest to you then
a fourth job is imminent oxana and
perhaps a fifth jab
well what we did see is is a drop in
antibodies but there is also uh studies
being done on t cell and b cell
protection and that cross-reactivity
which shows that um there will still be
levels of uh recognition within the body
to help uh fight off the pathogen so
it's i would say that although we have
some waning the point now is that it's
still quite effective in reducing
hospitalizations and that is really the
most important aspect around the
vaccination program in the ear of
omicron is to reduce symptoms severity
so even if there is a waning effect with
antibodies
which we are seeing with boosters
it may not necessarily mean that a
fourth dose is needed israel is acting
on very early data uh in this instance
and the who has recommended on waiting
for a stronger evidence base before
proceeding with that um but we know we
need to be making sure that while we
have a
booster program ruling that this doesn't
detract from uh vaccinating other
regions of the world so has to be and
and there are mechanisms for that to
happen uh it just needs the appropriate
cooperation and less politicization
around distribution as well as some
really practical on the ground things so
we need technology transfer as well as
ensuring that we have a support with
supply chains um and other practical
aspects to ensure that syringes are an
appropriate supply uh supporting
workforce it can't just be uh handing
over a blueprint there needs to be a
full package or suite of solutions to
ensure other countries can get up to
speed with it
was saying just to pick up on what oxana
was saying i wonder if you can weigh in
on this situation here because we also
know that there have been reports in
fact that nigeria for example had thrown
out a million vaccines because they had
expired so are african uh some african
countries getting um
the leftovers so to speak and how do you
change that
so uh this is more into politics i'm not
sure if i can commit too much about it
for me there's this kind of obligations
on wealthy nations to support um
unwealthy nations in terms of vaccines
right and
one thing i can point out is that
maybe some of these african countries
are getting let's say second or third
level uh vaccines rather than the
the best vaccine which are like the
messenger rna
but um i really cannot comment too much
about about this subject it's something
between between okay let's let's take it
to bengaluru then let's take it to
bengaluru and prasanna would you like to
weigh in on this
yes we should talk politics
and the whole vaccine inequities are
about politics
um for example there was a recent paper
which showed that there are about 100
companies around the world including
african countries where mrna vaccines
could have been manufactured
on a
what you call
ramped up scale
um but
we are seeing nowhere that it is
happening on top of it we are fattening
the purses of the ones who also i i
incidentally modena got the uh money
from uh public exchequer of united
states of america to manufacture the
mrna maxine and they are the costliest
maxine so
we need to talk politics we need to talk
about global health governance right and
it's not only that as oksana was saying
persona also it's not just the shortages
of the vaccine but in fact the logistics
so once the vaccines arrive into
countries um there are issues with
distribution there's issues with vaccine
hesitancy as well and have they arrived
when have they arrived is also the
politics so they might have been
arriving very late
um of course there are health system
deficiencies which we all know in
african countries but beyond that
actually there are papers which show
that for example the whole
supply of vaccines have been delayed
by um
the global mechanism that was put up and
for which
the african countries even received the
vaccines late
by which time they could i mean they
were not given prior intimation they
were not given um preparatory time
nothing and the vaccines landed like
that so there are issues multiple layers
of issues but one of the things that we
have to talk about is if there were to
be enough supplies then we would not
have had so much of bottlenecks
everywhere right that'll take a whole
other show
but we have to leave it there we've run
out of time let's hope the who chief is
correct when he's optimistic this year
uh can be the end thank you so much for
joining us uh hadiya seen oxana pizzic
and prasanna telegram we appreciate your
time and your thoughts thank you for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com for further discussion you
can go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can join the conversation on
twitter as well our handle is aj inside
story from myself and the whole team
here in doha thanks for watching and bye
bye for now
[Music]